if forced to choose
it's the sense of smell most people
believe they could live without
but losing it can be life-altering
scientists say covert attacks the cells
that help communicate what we're
smelling
we can lose our appetite or worse still
the will to live
sense of smell helps define who we are
[Music]
i'm ben fizzle fazeland nice to have you
along a study of two and a half thousand
patients who lost their sense of smell
and or taste showed forty percent of
them had completely regained it half a
year later
two percent reported no improvement
whatsoever for belgium and sophie lorcan
pleasant sense
such as her favorite perfumes smell
awful
after she got infected with kovid19 a
few months ago
at first she could no longer smell
anything
then many smells were distorted one of
the most common side effects of the
virus
she can only see the spring on her
balcony
there is a tiny bit of something but i
don't know the smell
that's frustrating and makes me a bit
sad
sean michelle mayar can understand very
well
how lokai is feeling the frenchman lost
his sense of smell due to an accident
five years ago
it's the smell of his children he misses
most
but maya does not want to give up his
passion for cooking
a bit of color is good we eat with our
eyes after all
a bit like the great chefs in france are
doing it
but it is the nose with its millions of
olfactory cells that defines the taste
of this salmon
after his accident maya was angry
because no one could help him
even if an estimated five percent of the
french population suffers from a
distorted sense of smell but with time
his anger gave way
to an idea he founded an association
and developed a factory training in
cooperation with scientists
with concentrated scents rose lemon
cloves the sense of smell
is a sense that is as important as other
senses
many forget about it most people only
discover it
once they've lost it since the beginning
of the pandemic thousands of affected
people
all over europe have been using his
sense of smell training techniques
belgian and sofia khan is also
exercising her nose
her doctor has seen for herself that
many patients are recovering thanks to
the training
for example because the olfactory cells
damaged by the virus
renew themselves this gives me hope
but my motivation varies and so does my
hope
because sometimes i'm just sad i keep
asking myself
if it will ever come back
even if things are getting better only
slowly and sophia lorca is hoping these
smell bottles
will help her put on her perfume again
without
upsetting her nose let's look at the
science surrounding this
pamela dalton is an old factory
scientist so pamela
just how quickly can people recover
their sense of smell because
the researchers i've spoken to say the
majority of covet sufferers are
massively
impaired you're correct
that they can be massively impaired
during the acute
form of the virus however fortunately
most people
do recover their ability to smell
sometimes within days or weeks
after the virus passes unfortunately
a small portion of individuals seem to
have a persistent loss
are they the ones who are suffering from
lung covert
in some cases smell loss is the only
symptom that they may have ever
experienced from covid
but yes some individuals with long covet
also do experience this persistent smell
loss
can go on beyond six months wow and and
what are the consequences of that i i
mean
i guess you you just don't want to eat
do you if it doesn't taste good and
there are lots of other things involved
like relationships and
depression it can really impact on your
life can't it
it can be very distressing particularly
for people who never thought that losing
their sense of smell
would have such a dramatic impact on
their life
eating is certainly the first thing that
is affected and some people actually
go in two different ways some people
stop eating because of the lack of
enjoyment of food
and some people overeat because they're
looking for that satisfaction that they
can no longer get from food flavor
a sorry what were you going to say
uh loss of smell can also change
your relationships with your environment
and the people around you
familiar places and familiar people no
longer seem quite the same
when you cannot smell them so are
scientists any closer to agreeing on
why this happens
there are intriguing studies being
published
almost every week we know for example
that the virus does attack
certain types of cells that express the
ace2 receptor
but it looks like the persistent loss of
smell may be more associated with
ongoing viral replication and
inflammation
in the nasal passages in the
neuroepithelium where
all of the cells that support our sense
of smell are located
why does the virus do this because it's
basically
giving itself away it's a clear sign
you're about to become infectious and
most people would quarantine themselves
of course and prevent the virus from
spreading
well actually that's a really
interesting question because
until it was made clear that sudden loss
of smell
was a cardinal symptom of saris cov2
infection
most people really didn't understand
what was going on with them
if they experienced a fever for example
or
severe muscle aches or extreme coughing
they might have isolated
but many people who suddenly lost their
sense of smell were not actually
quarantining themselves
until the message got out that this was
indeed
one of the best ways to know whether
someone had been infected with the virus
we also mentioned earlier in the show
that the olfactory cells are able to
renew themselves
and regularly is that the same for
everyone though
well in the normal human sense of smell
yes
the olfactory neurons regenerate
throughout the lifespan
unfortunately when there is disruption
by
a virus that can lead to inflammation
this can actually attack the system in
multiple ways
it can produce inflammation as i said
earlier i can
also attack the supporting cells that
are involved
in the regeneration process and some
viruses also attack the olfactory
neurons themselves
and what's your take on smell training
and its effectiveness
at the present time smell training seems
to be
the best recommendation for people who
have persistent smell loss
following covent infection it's
it requires some persistence and
compliance
it doesn't work if you only do it
casually but the evidence is that if you
stick with the program which generally
involves
about 12 weeks of smelling four
odorants twice a day and doing it very
mindfully that approximately half of the
people that have been in studies
actually do regain their sense of smell
and do so faster
than people who don't undertake smell
training
so it's a lot of work but definitely
worth it in the long run you say
if you're depressed if your lifestyle
has changed because you can no longer
smell the people the places the food you
enjoy eating
then it certainly is a worthwhile effort
it has
very little risk except for perhaps
boredom and a little frustration in the
early days
but it has been shown to have efficacy
in post-viral smell loss and so
therefore
it is one of the recommended treatments
good to hear pamela dalton thanks for
joining us today on the show
pleasure my pleasure thank you
over to derrick williams now he's got an
interesting view of question about
natural immunity
[Music]
how long does natural immunity acquired
from having the disease
last this is another question
where a little background comes in handy
um
when you're infected by a pathogen for
the first time
your body forms what's called an
immunological
memory of it now experts say these kinds
of memories
are in some ways like neurological
memories a few
will stay with you throughout your life
while others
will disappear after just a few months
when it comes to covet 19
we still don't know exactly how long
immunity and those who recovered will on
average
last but several studies including one
from early february that's been cited a
lot
they indicate that in most people who
caught the disease
naturally acquired immunity seems to
remain
pretty robust for quite a while the
study looked at a range of factors
associated with an ongoing immune
response
in people who'd recovered from covet 19
and it found
that in the overwhelming majority of
them immune memory
remained apparently strong at least six
months
after recovery many experts are now
hopeful
that that most people who had the
disease could prove
resistant to reinfection for at least a
year and hopefully longer
that's good news though it's likely not
the whole
story with other coronaviruses
immune memory tends to lapse over time
which is
why authorities also recommend that
people who had covet 19
and recovered still get vaccinated at
least once
because vaccines provide a safe way
to update and refresh immune memory
and could potentially make you even more
resistant to saris kobe 2
and for a longer period of time then
natural
infection alone would
[Music]
and to end the show we leave you with
the dutch scientists who've taught
bees to sniff out covert 19.
researchers gave them sugary water as a
reward for identifying positive samples
only
once they got used to the system they'd
stick out their tongues automatically
the results can be provided in just
seconds
of course bees have a keen sense of
smell let's hope they
don't lose it from covert thanks for
joining us on dwu's
covert 19 special